elle était particulière à plus d'un
titre à la rentrée scolaire en ce lundi
2 novembre nouveau protocole sanitaire
renforcée avec le port du masque
obligatoire pour les enfants à partir de
6 ans al-arich d'ailleurs la
municipalité distribué deux masques par
élève
et puis c'était le jour hommage à samuel
pâtit avec un temps pédagogique autour
de la liberté d'expression sébastien
branger devant l'école paul-bert de la
riche
les enfants se pressent au portillon
masque sur le visage et sous le regard
protecteur d'un policier municipal une
étrange rentrée car depuis ce matin tous
les élèves à partir de 6 ans doivent
effectivement porter un masque une
mesure à laquelle les enfants doivent
s'habituer bon gré mal gré va n'a pas
présenté mais surtout à l'apache on dit
que c'est pour les protéger puis voilà
c'est pas c'est pas une punition
c'est pour mettre un petit peu de gaieté
dans ce moment un petit peu triste parce
que des enfants de 6 ans à partir disant
avoir un masque c'est pas évident moi il
ça me fait un peu rigoler parce que y'a
macao des masses est rigolo et puis moi
ça me dérange pas face à l'urgence
l'édile de la riche est d'ailleurs venu
à porter des masques confectionnés
durant le premier confinement voilà ça
va permettre d'aider les familles de les
dépanner même si j'ai vu et c'est une
bonne nouvelle beaucoup d'enfants dès ce
matin tu es venu avec leur masque
parfois des masques pour adultes
confectionnèrent confectionner maison
cette rentrée est aussi placée sous le
signe de l'hommage à samuel pâtit le
professeur assassiné la veille des
vacances scolaires
devant le l'acte odieux qui a eu lieu il
était évidemment impossible de faire une
rentrée sans marquer l'hommage à ceux à
ce héros de la laïcité
l'hommage aux professeurs c'est d'abord
une minute de silence et un texte de
jean jaurès lui à tous les élèves du
pays
vous tenez dans vos mains l'intelligence
et et l'âme des enfants
vous êtes responsable de la patrie que
je pense que c'est important
que que les enfants comprennent tout ce
qui s'est passé là pendant ses vacances
suite à ce drame
voilà et on va aborder le sujet sous
différentes choses un temps débat
philosophique arts visuels écriture
le texte de jean jaurès ainsi que des
éléments pédagogiques autour du thème de
la laïcité sont téléchargeables sur le
site de l'éducation nationale et du skol
point éducation point fr